[Music]
Jim whatever i do i do it to protect you
see I understand I understand
[Applause]
you want to get me here
[Music]
our rebellion is all that remains to
push back the Empire if your name for
the record gen are so forgery of
Imperial documents possession of stolen
property aggravated assault resisting
arrest on your own from the age of 15
reckless aggressive and undisciplined
this is a rebellion isn't it I rebell
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
when was the last time you're wearing
contact with your father what is this
with a mission for you a major weapons
test is imminent we need to know how to
destroy it is that clear yes sir I've
been recruiting for the rebellion for a
long time all this as the force will see
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
Thanks power that we are dealing with
here is immeasurable
if the Empire has this kind of power
what chance do we have we have hope
rebellions are built on hope if you're
really doing this I want
good
good well rebellion is
it remains to push back the Empire
the world is coming undone imperial
flags rain across the galaxy this is our
chance
[Music]
it appears he is critical to the
development of a super weapon
they are requesting a call sign it some
rogue rogue one
may the force be with us
have no idea we're coming
take hold of this moment
are you with me all the way
[Music]